en vain la parole est à monsieur jean
claude guibal merci madame la présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
ministre
venus de syrie mais aussi d'irak
d'afghanistan d'erythrée d'ethiopie et
du sud soudan des migrants aborde par
centaines de milliers au rivage
méditerranéen de l'europe
ils étaient 280 2000 en 2014
ils sont déjà plus de 700 milles cette
année et il semblerait qu'il soit
potentiellement plus d'un million cinq
cent mille l'europe a tardé à prendre la
mesure de ce mouvement migratoire
puissant et sans doute durable elle a de
surcroît amplifiée par des déclarations
souvent contradictoires nous aurions
tort de nous en étonner
l'europe ne s'est jamais vraiment
préoccupé de protéger ses frontières ni
de se doter d'une politique migratoire
elle a préféré se penser comme un grand
marché dotée d'une monnaie unique
aujourd'hui à défaut d'avoir anticipé
les conséquences des conflits qui
bouleverse le wayne orient elle envisage
enfin de renforcer la lutte contre les
migrants économiques par des mesures que
nous réclamons depuis fort longtemps
j'en cite quelques exemples vous l'avez
fait tout à l'heure monsieur le premier
ministre il s'agit de l'augmentation
significative du taux de reconduite
je rappelle qu'il n'est que de 1 sur 5
en france il s'agit du renforcement du
contrôle des frontières extérieures de
la création de gardes frontières de la
possibilité d'utiliser si nécessaire les
centres d'accueil comme centre de
rétention ou bien encore de renforcer la
coopération entre les pays d'origine ou
de transit
monsieur le ministre la france soutient
soutiendra-t-elle ces mesures à
l'occasion du conseil européen qui
débute demain et proposera tel aussi
de repenser les accords de schengen pour
qu'ils permettent d'assurer une
protection efficace de nos frontières
je vous remercie merci la parole dans le
fair ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
député je vous remercie pour votre
question extrêmement précises qui envoie
un ensemble de préoccupations qui sont
celles du gouvernement d'abord je veux
rappeler qu'elle a été la chronologie
des faits quelles ont été les actions
que nous avons engagées au cours des
derniers mois le 30 août 2014
précisément c'est à dire plus d'un an
avant que ne s'enclenche la crise
migratoire laquelle nous sommes
confrontés
je m'étais rendu dans les principales
capitales européennes à la demande du
président de la république et du premier
ministre pour formuler les propositions
françaises quelles étaient ses
propositions d'abord mettre fin à
l'opération marenostrum une opération de
sauvetage en mer décidés unilatéralement
par les sites ya lien qui avait eu pour
principale vertu de sauver davantage de
vies m'avait qu'à la fin plus de morts
contrôler les frontières extérieures de
l'union européenne organisée avec les
pays de provenance des conventions de
retour pour lutter contre l'immigration
économique irrégulière lutter contre les
filières de passeurs mettre en place les
fondements d'une politique européenne de
l'asile voilà quels étaient les
propositions de la france il ya un an
ces propositions nous les avons
mutualisé avec l'allemagne elles sont
devenues les propositions de l'union
européenne il faut maintenant tirer un
bilan
la france en matière d'abord de lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière vous
indiquer la nécessité d'augmenter les
reconduites à la frontière c'est tout à
fait ce que nous faisons les reconduites
forcées à la frontière était de 12 mille
en 2010 elles seront de 17000 à la fin
de l'année 2015 pourquoi parce que nous
pensons qu'il n'y a aucune chance de
pouvoir accueillir convenablement les
réfugiés si nous ne luttons pas contre
eux l'immigration économique irrégulière
nous nous battons pour que frontex monte
en puissance
nous nous battons pour la mise en place
des hotspots nous insistons pour que
madame mot guerre inique et un mandat de
l'union européenne négocient des
conventions de retour
et nous travaillons avec l'allemagne à
une politique européenne de l'asile
voilà la politique de la france nous la
mènerons sans trêve ni pause
merci la parole est à monsieur